as I mentioned before I'm taking a full
year to be single and focus on myself
and my career I even put a ring on it
and of course when you announce
something definitive like this life
decides to challenge your resolve oh
sorry sorry no that was never my fault
no that's my thought it's mine Nana huh
do you want to do the Daniel Radcliffe
collab or not oh yeah yeah of course of
course his eyes are so deep yes life
literally through me Daniel Radcliffe
and though everything that you're about
to see never happened it's something
that I had to seriously consider because
let's be honest here in my imagination
this was my potential future I would
offer to buy you a coffee but you
obviously already have one so I take you
out to dinner oh I am
how could you married I'm so sorry I
didn't realize oh no no I'm not I'm not
married what then oh I bought this for
myself this is you know for me from me
I'm committed to being single for a year
you bought that for yourself yeah that
is a large diamond yeah well join me
we'll see how much that cost don't judge
me okay
no government and llego me right
sticking to my resolve but my imaginary
Daniel Radcliffe was oddly insightful
what did he meet the right person well I
figure you know if I meet the right
person that way for me
don't think love unfold naturally
well yeah but what if I'm not ready are
we ever ready for anything you can't
control the situation you're in all you
can do is react to it as openly and as
honestly as you possibly can it wait is
that an invitation to kiss you no no no
okay just checking
and when realistic fantasies like this
happen you have to reevaluate your
decisions I vowed to be single for a
year he has a point
life happens but I haven't worked on
myself I'm not comfortable being alone I
hate being alone I have four cats and I
still feel so alone you can still work
on yourself and love someone else in
fact all the best relationships are
where you work on yourselves together
how would you know you're me and we've
never had that to shy
Allen you spent the last 10 years living
in serial monogamist and are you just
doing the same thing with being single
stop living in extremes just evaluate
where you're at when moments happen and
make decisions then you don't have to
lay down blanket rules for yourself just
live in the moment you're right you're
perfect and you're right I love you
what nothing yeah no I'm gonna follow
your advice I'm not gonna commit to
extremes but right now I know that I
need to learn how to be independent so
but this is the sheesh you may be the
right person it's just the wrong time
you're British accent a superhot though
keep it thanks so much to Daniel for
filming with us you can check out his
new film what if in theaters today it's
really exciting to see him take on all
sorts of different genres in his career
hey good luck to you sir Oh Ana meeting
him in real life was more like this
Thank You art director Ana hi nice to
meet you I just came Christ me too I'll
see you next week
stay awesome Gotham I have four cats
okay
that's useful information yeah
hi I just came fantastic
that's it we'll go again voices wails
yeah me too yeah that'd be good
that's nice that helps my self-esteem I
want to do him we all do no but I'm
going to yes ma'am yeah
make it happen no pencil put it on the
shot was please